[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rhett and I was yawning
sorry but that really says that I'm the
tone
um I'm link this week at the round table
of dim lighting we're doing something a
little bit different
um we're we're compiling
how do I how do I describe it is a
thematic compilation yes we're compiling
things our friendships around the same
theme
um but it's going to create something
entirely new so instead of while we take
a break just you know just giving you uh
another episode you may have not heard
we thought it would be fun to in this
case go through our friendship series
which we Revisited like we take a few
months we revisit and we analyzed our
friendship during different time periods
thinking that we could then
on our some new stories and some new
insights into what was it like being
friends in grade school middle school
high school college our engineering
years and so we've kind of taken the
highlights you know a segment from each
one of those things so you can you know
you'll be on a journey through our
friendship through the years uh without
having to go back and listen to all
those yeah enjoy it
every single interview even to this day
next week if we have an interview with
somebody for a publication we will say
on the first day of first grade we were
both held in from Recess for writing
nasty words on our desks I wrote
hell and I wrote damn I'm not really
sure who says what yeah and sometimes we
don't say that yeah I'm gonna say yeah
and that's when we met our teacher Miss
Locklear helped us in from recess and
made us let's just say it together color
pictures of mythical beasts
and that's when we hit it off and that's
why our company is called mythical and
that's why everything we do is called
something mythical and that's why our
fans call themselves mythical beasts yes
because of that origin story and you
know what we've been best friends ever
since
you don't want to ruin it for everybody
do you here's the thing when we started
talking about this recently you okay I'm
gonna say something that I believe is
true about you and that is you have an
uncanny ability to look back on
something and change the detail and then
believe it to be true and just and
bypass the whole like this is probably
not exactly what happened like because
there's lots of things that you've said
and I'm like but you know that's
actually not like that's actually not
true right you that's the way that
you've categorized it and smoothed it
out in your mind I've always had
feelings about it let's analyst the
story and then explain it okay I think
yes you're on to something you're on to
something but so let's let's break it
apart
we did meet and first of all that we
have not discussed this at length it's
not like we're about to confess
something to you that we've concluded
that we've been lying to you this is a
legitimate exercise right now in your
presence of us analyzing this
mythologized story
so we certainly I have analyzed it on my
own a few times but certainly met in
first grade in Miss Locklear's class in
1984 in Bowie's Creek and we were
certainly both there the first day we
were definitely both there the first day
now
I'm gonna go back to what I remember I'm
gonna try to get back to what I actually
remember
I remember
both of us getting in trouble
and I remember both of us being held in
from Recess
and I remember both of us coloring
pictures
and I know and judge and looking at how
you were coloring and making a judgment
about it very
an early accounts
of that story
included the memory from me uh again now
I'm just remembering the remembering of
the memories which is what humans do
anyway well but I'm going back to what I
think is our core because because a
couple of things core memory but there's
a couple of things about that that I'll
get into it I I remember
Paul Bunyan and Babe the Blue Ox like
there was a point when I accessed that
as what I believe to be a core memory of
what
we were coloring or I was coloring
I now that memory came from you yes the
fact that it was from it was Paul Bunyan
because I don't remember what we were
coloring
um
I mean so I I don't have an opinion
about that here's here's what I believe
to here's if I if you put me up against
the wall here's what I believe
I don't think it was the first day of
first grade okay I don't think that we
were I don't think we got in trouble on
the first day of first grade it's like a
simplification I think what happened was
we we it's safe to say that we met in
some form because you pretty much in
some form you meet everybody in your
class on the first day of
first grade yeah yeah yeah and that's
when you moved from California I was
there in kindergarten you weren't
you know and I remember that on the
first day of first grade but then at
some point we both got in trouble
well I know we both got in trouble
because I you know but back in the day
they used to give the uh I could see the
numbers on conduct
and it was the higher the number the
worse it was
and if it was uh and four was the worst
and I always got Force
any but the reason I always got four is
talkative it's because I just wouldn't
shut up
I once sat next to you and colored and
made observations about the nature of
the way you were coloring and I was like
wow he's like really precise it's like
go on what does he try like I remember
thinking like was he trying to prove it
was like because what did I prove
because first grade you know what I'm
saying first grade is like most kids in
first grade are just like they're
holding this is what I was doing you're
holding the crayon like this like you're
holding it like you're gonna kill
somebody you're gonna like stab somebody
with a crown and then it just makes
contact with the paper and you just move
it and I'm just like yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then I look me not know what wheel
is and you're like
it's like really even I'm like wow is he
is he submitting this to a contest
because I didn't know this was a contest
and now I need to try you know what I'm
saying oh no this is just art time I'm
not we're I'm not interested in this uh
but I know that that happened but I I'm
not willing to stand by the fact that
that those two events coincided and it
was actually why we were being punished
well it sounds like at least three
events have been combined into one you
remember us coloring yeah we know we met
on the first day of first grade had to
and we know we got in trouble at some
point at the same time
well I'm sure that that happened okay so
those three things were compiled into
one mythologized origin story I would
like to talk a little bit about first
impressions as I remember them
okay we've already talked a little bit
about my impression of like how you're
coloring
but and I actually didn't I had to kind
of dig back and think like what what do
I remember thinking about link
in meeting him now I've already
established that my
Mo was to
I was I wasn't I didn't perceive you as
timid
but I know that I definitely was not
timid in terms of my I threw myself at
people right in a way that I don't do
now like I'm more of an introvert but I
was a weird extrovert in like Elementary
School in the way that I would just like
meet somebody and then within the first
five minutes invite myself to spend the
night at their house that night
I did with anybody
and
so I was very drawn to now I'm wondering
if everything you're saying is an
oversimplification like the first time
you met him you'd invite yourself over
that's an oversimplification it is but
very very early like alarmingly early
usually in the first day
I would be like hey so like uh you what
do you think about sleepovers I know you
know I would it's just I'd find a way to
that's all true
um so I was but I would you know I was
kind of evaluating like oh this person
seems uh there's something here like
this person seems like they'd be fun or
like we could have a good time together
right so obviously I thought that about
you because I'm pretty sure we had
sleepovers in first grade
but here's the thing that I remember
about you I find that hard to believe
okay maybe maybe I just seems really
early for me okay I remember thinking
that you were very clean clean speaking
of hygiene that you were like very put
together like you had this like your
hair it was like it's like somebody's
like he's really he really was caring
about like his hair and his clothes
somebody's combing them his hair is
combed his his his his clothes like ah
match like someone is like laying them
out or he's cares about it like you know
I'm wearing like gray sweatpants and a
gray sweatshirt you're like that's an
outfit I'm there you know what I mean
I'm trying to think what my first
impressions of you were because I
I I have to kind of interpolate from
from the facts that I know I I don't and
maybe I'll access a memory but nothing
specific comes to mind like it does for
you it's like I'm so good I made such a
strong impression on so many visceral in
specific memories but it wasn't but it
but because it was different just what
I'll say that like
I felt like most of the other kids sort
of seem like yeah like we're in first
grade
we're just we're just kind of like going
with it existing yeah but it was like oh
this kid is like he's put together it's
picture day every day for this kid but
yeah yeah yeah
yeah right yeah yes definitely
and for the reasons that I mentioned I
think that um you know it I don't think
it was anything that I analyzed it was
just the the opinions in my life
basically my mom but you don't think
that I never questioned it you don't
think that you I never looked around I
don't think I was I was self-conscious I
do have this early uh preschool memory
of like
I was the guys were so rambunctious and
physical like there was like wrestling
happening in preschool and
I was afraid of the guys and I would I
would always hang out with the girls
like the guys would climb this
um Fort structure built indoors at the
Lillington First Baptist Church and be
up there and I would in doing
rambunctious stuff and I was just
intimidated and so I would hang out with
the girls what and no I didn't yeah
kindergarten version of that I didn't
know you at that time but what I do
remember along those lines is that it
was a very quickly he's not he's not
interested in sports now again I wasn't
I didn't have a uh yeah
I've never really been that like
J I'm not a judgmental person you know
what I'm saying so it's so so it's not
like he's not interested in sports so
therefore he's not my friend like no
that kind of thing does that happen
apparently it was he's different I gotta
see his house yeah yeah I gotta spend
the night like but it was clear that
like even in first grade I remember in
first grade first second grade talking
to other boys about you know like J.R
Reed's coming to Carolina like that's a
con that's a level of conversation that
I would have with these other kids who
like cared about
college sports and like what was
happening at Carolina and state and Duke
at the time right and a lot of that
comes from the fact that like okay my
dad was really into sports and all these
other kids dads really into sports and
had a brother and that kind of thing but
it was like that wasn't a conversation I
was gonna have with you that it was like
okay well I'm gonna have a different
conversation with this with this guy my
first impression of you had to have been
related to the fact that like you
weren't there the year before
in kindergarten you were you were taller
than everybody yeah you had this you had
this look about you it looks like you
know
but you have bigger eyes
and you were gangly and if you did just
say if you got down on all fours I'm not
gonna say that's like you know how in
like The Fellowship of the Ring they had
they put Gollum in there for a few
seconds but you didn't really like they
hadn't fully figured out who Gollum was
they hadn't done all the CGI so like in
Two Towers he's fully fleshed out and
looks looks different but in like the
first one he's kind of like the
shadowing new character that you don't
really know and like boy he's really
hunched over and you can kind of count
all of his vertebrae and boy there's a
he looks like he has some extra
vertebrae and his eyes are so big you're
talking probably what I thought you were
talking about whatever I'm not gonna say
because I don't remember you're talking
but factually that's not true because I
I look that way
during and shortly after puberty I
actually was just kind of a tall kid but
proportionally I'm relatively normal
okay I began looking like golluminth
grade I was just joking
okay well it's a good joke
earbiscus is brought to you by better
help if you're anything like me you
spend a fair amount of energy
trying to
let's say live up to the expectations
that you think that people have of you
you know living a life that's focused on
uh appearing a certain way externally
and sometimes you can end up neglecting
your inner life yeah and yourself and
that's actually something that therapy
has really helped me with and even
though we're performers you don't have
to be a performer to feel like you're
performing right for people yeah it's
really easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you but what
about what you need from you right
that's where therapy so useful it can
really be that time you work on just
yourself with no interference from
others and that's why we like better
help yeah I'm fans of better help
because it is it makes therapy more
accessible to more people and maybe that
includes you if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so you can take
your appointments from anywhere on your
own schedule just fill out a
questionnaire and better help will match
you with a therapist that meets your
needs and you can change their
therapists at any time with no extra
cost find more balance with better help
visit betterhelp.com ear today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com ear
let's get into middle school so for us
Middle School
was kind of a continuation of Elementary
School Bowie's Creek Elementary went
from kindergarten all the way through
eighth grade but there was the middle
school hallway the whole thing was
shaped like a like a z
well a very straight Z
like Steps
and then you what is that that should be
a little but but why is that not a
letter so like the bottom row of your Z
is the it's like an H with the two if
you look at an h and you just grab the
top end on the left and the bottom in on
the right and you tear them off yeah
that should be a letter I guess like
knowing that layout of the school is not
really the thing I wanted to that was
spending that much time on it but I over
the years you would move up the
elementary school hallway and then when
you would you would start going to the
next hallway but that was like
fifth grade maybe sixth grade but you
weren't considered definitely sixth
grade but you weren't considered middle
school there until seventh grade and the
reason is because that's when your class
schedule changed from one teacher all
day to multiple classes where you went
to three different teachers yep and we
were in the same class
for all of those so we moved around
together both years both years all of
the
yeah once you were in a class together
it kind of that that was you stayed in
that lump yeah but you got but you got a
locker
yeah you got a locker lock it for the
first time you could play you could play
sports because that was when you could
like get on the basketball team or the
um before that it was we both played on
the soccer but it was before that we had
done Recreation soccer but this was like
school soccer yeah School baseball
school basketball and it was it was so
it was kind of cool that like your whole
uh School career you kind of saw this
whole trajectory and you could see the
the middle schoolers you could see those
eighth graders coming into the lunchroom
and stuff so it was like it it you
really had something to Aspire to
because it was right there in front of
you and it wasn't a huge scary deal to
go to the middle school because it was
just going further down the hall it was
one of the more easy it was the easier
transition that I can think of for most
people having to go to like a whole new
place and new friends it's like it's
everybody I was in school with before
with like the one new person from
Nebraska that shows up you know to me
this is all wrapped up in the talent
show which we have talked about before
but at the end of the year the the
it was that those three teachers were in
charge of putting the talent show on so
any student could sign up for what they
wanted to do and then there'd be that
assembly during school hours where
everybody would come in and sit in the
auditorium and the seventh and 8th
graders will perform their talents and
then what I've been thinking about this
from
just intently from first grade oh yeah
because it's like these are celebrities
in school celebrities getting up there
how and I get a performance performing a
song and like there would always be this
big Grim finale like the biggest act
would be at the end and you'd go in
there and you'd look you'd look forward
to it and then they would do it again
that night for the parents would come in
so you'd have two performances so by the
time I didn't even remember that yeah by
the time we were in seventh grade and we
had practiced in sixth grade because the
Fall Festival we did opp and made it
down with Halloween that was sixth grade
and we talked our way into that yep
there was not supposed to be a
performance of any kind
did that thing and we were like we got
to get ready for this talent show we got
to know what it's like to be up on this
stage in this Auditorium and perform for
a full house yeah so by the time as
seventh graders
we formed our Posse and picked out our
rap song that we were going to perform
we did um we had a big Posse we did
Digital Underground same song
which had Tupac in it
and uh then we added on and that and
then our friend Ben Greenwood he came
out with his uh his uh drum machine
not on though and he he didn't turn it
on no because we played the track that's
right
we added a second song on to the end of
it maybe that was eighth grade seventh
grade was huge because it was our first
year doing it and we like they didn't
put us last but they put us close to
last and like we we really showed up the
final act I don't remember what the
eighth graders did everybody forgot them
by the time we were eighth grade we knew
we were gonna do
so what's the what's so what's the
scenario by A Tribe Called Quest
yeah and we have more people in our
Posse but there was a big deal and one
of the reasons that was like that was
like a Victory lap the seventh grade
the really coming of age we show songs
that had different
Parts different rappers in it because it
was like you can represent like these
people can each be represented by
someone and so the scenario had what
like
four five people rapping in it maybe six
um
man those were the good all day so yeah
so that just a picture oh gosh that's
who we were at the time we were just
thinking about being on stage and
Performing and getting getting attention
but also I was in a place where my sixth
grade year had ended with my first ever
girlfriend a one month long relationship
with Leslie there's a video on YouTube
because she happens to be Link's first
girlfriend too where we called her and
reminisced yeah on the Vlog Channel
um because yes seventh grade
yeah yeah I I found out we were in
different sixth grade classes I find out
you were dating her
and then I was like
first of all this is how I find out like
you didn't tell me
like I that's an indication of like
sixth grade being in different classes
you start going with Leslie and I didn't
know ahead of time that's an indicator
about like
that was just something that we didn't
talk about
you know I don't maybe we weren't so
close maybe it was just something you
don't I was only talking to the people
that I felt were necessary to pull it
off which was her best friend Amber who
then became my girlfriend in eighth
grade right but you didn't talking to
you about it wouldn't have caused it to
happen so there was no reason to consult
with you about it unless we were like
really good friends Rhett I didn't talk
to anybody other than Tate I talked to
Tate because Tate was also interested in
her oh you used to trying to box him out
I did box him out by telling him dude
I'm I'm I'm I'm going I think I said
something it's my turn May the best man
win but just so you know I'm also
interested I'm sure you didn't say me
the best man
but my mentality now first of all that
relationship lasted one month there was
no hanky-panky there was nothing not
even a holding there was a holding of a
hand at one dance that was it no kissing
I wanted to it didn't have the nerve
but I'm bringing the possibility of what
it's like to have finally been in a
relationship and I've already made it
very clear that from very early on I was
girl crazy
but the thing that I had was
the girl craziness without any game
whatsoever right I had no idea how to
talk to girls my go-to move was just
staring
um you know and waiting to see if they
stare back like it was I was so not good
and it's like thing is is that I was
actually a pretty sociable person and I
was oh I wanted to get up in front of
the school and I wanted to give a speech
in front of class
I wasn't awkward in those settings but
when it came to women I just didn't know
how to proceed at all I just had this
really high level of desire and then no
game at all but but that did give you an
edge because I think a lot of kids were
still like me I was very timid and I was
like
Frozen
but you weren't Frozen you took action
yeah so my actions were my actions were
sort of characterized by timidity in one
sense though like like I don't know what
yeah but you do I'm gonna talk to the
friend I did not I did not talk to
friends I did not you didn't do anything
I didn't do anything so I'll give you
credit for that I mean I was having a
conversation with Amber in history class
and she kept talking to me about the boy
she liked that happened to be you and I
kept I kept trying to guess who it was
and I was guessing all these people and
then I I think I probably guessed
everybody except me until I realized it
was me and then we started going
together right because it was I never it
never it was never that easy for me just
so you just so you know if it had been
that made it for me it was so easy yet I
made it so different if I hadn't had the
desire that I had but then the level of
interest from girls that you had
it you know what I would be the father
of a lot of children right now or so
something would say it would be bad you
know what I'm saying like it's not
necessarily bad having a lot of kids a
full quiver
I mean okay yeah you're right Proverbs
just say something like that
um but so in seventh grade me and Amber
started going together that's when I had
my first kiss
at the uh
at the Lillington Ruritan Club ruatan
building for somebody's birthday but who
were you so seventh grade seventh grade
was a dry spell for me you were you were
you weren't even at I was primed and
ready and uh pubed up and everything
but uh
just that was let me say there was
primed and ready and pubed up there were
things happening
there were things happening the plumbing
was working and the plumbing was working
often
I mean it was I tested it constantly
right right I was so ready so ready
you weren't even testing your plumbing
at that time were you no
golly so much missed opportunity
I mean one tends to catch up
seventh grade was the last year that Ben
was in school before he went to Home
School
uh into homeschool because of his
chronic fatigue syndrome and so by
eighth grade he was basically not there
he didn't go to church with us but we
would still you know uh
he still participated in the talent show
with us we still go to his house and
like do dance routines and learn like
rap songs and stuff so I mean y'all were
still very tight but the amount of time
it was this point where we became more
of a three some well I would say
friendship I think we were more of a
threesome earlier and I think this is
when with Ben's chronic fatigue there
were days when I would call over there
and Miss Greenwood would answer the the
uh the phone and she'd be like Ben it's
not Ben can't do anything right now yeah
and as a seventh grader
um
especially me I just was not I've never
been I I still haven't problems like
right with talking to people so which
we've already talked about that but this
is so so that ended up being this thing
where okay I'm not spending this time
with Ben I'm not doing this thing like
every day during the summer between
fifth grade and sixth grade
I was going to be at Ben's house doing
something and you would be there a lot
right but like the default was we're
going to Keith Hills to do something and
and that was changing now it became this
is when like in the book of mythicality
we're talking about you and I riding
riding our bikes and meeting at the
midpoint at the middle of town yeah and
I had enough confidence as a seventh
grader to start riding my bike
everywhere and spending the night at
your house more often and that's when
like we could start doing the flashlight
Wars and we would go to the Keith Hills
gate you would I would come along for
the things that you've been doing for
years with your neighborhood friends
like
setting off fireworks at the gate and
having the security guard show up or
like the campus police for Campbell
University and they would get on the
loudspeaker and say boys we know you're
in the woods come out I loved it and
then I would start to come out and
realize I was the only one walking out
and then I wouldn't walk out and then
we'd like we would Sprint back to your
house and I was so much slower that me
and your neighbor Heather
weren't fast enough to keep up and we
got caught in the headlights of the
security car and then we had to go talk
to the security guard
but he gave us a really strong lecture
and let us go because the re because you
ditched us yeah man you got I mean
everything for myself
um so yeah I was kind of getting in the
mix there and and like having more
sleepovers and and starting starting to
gain confidence was registering with me
by the way and when things didn't
register I don't think things registered
things registered with me in terms of
like because I remember basketball was
another thing where like I mean we were
definitely best friends by this point
and it was and church was the engine and
then school was just icing on the cake
but like you were on the basketball team
as a seventh grader and eighth grader of
course but like
uh I find it wild that we did play
soccer together that's something that I
tend to forget I want to come back to
the basketball but like you were the
goalie right yeah much to my I didn't
know you were like it because you were
so big I was like I should be over there
scoring goals man
and I played um
I like soccer I was pretty good at it at
defense
you know I couldn't run a lot I wasn't I
didn't have a lot of stamina hence the
uh security guard thing but I could I
could uh play some good defense yeah
because Sports were becoming a really
big part of my life and of course I was
going to play everything that they were
that we were allowed to play which that
was those were the three sports soccer
baseball and basketball and I was just
hanging on by the soccer thread okay and
again I didn't know that you we because
we didn't talk about these things now as
a kid a parent of teenage boys I get the
fact that you're just not there's a
whole part of your brain that you're not
really using and you really look back on
these things reflectively but but I'm
thinking of things like
he's playing basketball like and he
practices basketball so much like this
really infringes on us being able to
hang out I I believe I'm pretty positive
that the reason why I started keeping
score for the girls basketball team was
because it gave me something to do that
like I was attached I would I traveled
with the basketball team with the boys
and girls and then so I could I'm gonna
go on the bus I got to go on the bus and
I could keep keep score for the girls
and then just watch the boys game
because I thought it was cooler to be
able to watch the boys game versus keep
up with it yeah
Pandora though she was tough to keep up
with she was tough to keep up with that
machine yeah just just to lay up Tyrant
but
that wasn't that was part of my equation
you know it's like I want to be in the
mix I want to you know what's my what's
my middle school identity I'm okay with
being the score keeper if I can be on
the bus if I can be in the mix and you
were so you were processing things on
that level I remember that yeah
yeah to me but I also knew that I would
never talk about it because it's like
talking about your feelings and being
being needy is just a real sign of
weakness like what what am I supposed to
say it's like well can I
can I do you think I can be a
scorekeeper but no so that we can we can
spend time together but but just to
clarify
are you like our kids talk about that
stuff
it's a it's it is very much a
generational and also a geographical
thing it was probably kids in certain
places in the world
and we're in our community that just
wasn't how you process Life as a kid
right so for me it was just like oh
there's a sport I can play it I can be
good at it okay it never crossed my mind
that do it do do I want like am I having
fun it wasn't about having fun it was
about winning it never crossed my mind
it was just like you have to be as good
as you possibly can at this and of
course you have to be as good as you
possibly can at this and you have to be
as good as you possibly can at this and
it wasn't just Sports it's like oh you
also have to be as good as you possibly
can at academics you have to be as good
as you possibly can at the talent show
at giving a speech for the class you
but it didn't feel like pressure
it just felt like a way of being it's
the yeah this is the plan I mean and it
was such a tight-knit community like in
our
uh Middle School classes uh seventh and
eighth grade we had the same three
teachers Miss wakeus Miss mcclam and Mr
Royal who was also the basketball coach
P coach health teacher
um and I
you know the our group of friends
whenever something would happen or
there'd be like Strife if there would be
drama with the girls and sometimes it
would involve guys and dating and
sometimes it would be us doing like
stupid stuff
but regardless of what happened that
like there was drama or trouble
all three teachers would take it upon
themselves to hold a tribunal to resolve
it they wouldn't send anybody to the
principal's office uh they were sparing
him because he had the rest of the
school and I think that they like to be
more heavy-handed than he was I think
that middle school is when
people began to think of us as a Duo
yeah right yeah the teachers yep that's
what if you got called into something I
would get and vice versa the our friends
it's like oh Rhett and Link they're a
Duo
and
again this was not like an intentional
thing but it was like oh there's a
school dance
there's the lip sync contest it was like
oh well we're gonna do DJ Jazzy Jeff and
The Fresh Prince because they're the
ultimate Duo we're the ultimate Duo
we started performing together we
started seeing ourselves as a team if we
could work together on a project like if
there was a way to be like hey we're
going to do this Oedipus video that's
right and we used Anna's video camera
and we did our first video and it was
like we were kind of thinking about it
in that way and then we did a whole
different one over at Heather's house
yeah the next year there was a cornfield
and like a scarecrow yeah
um but we started we just naturally fell
into this creative partnership that's
right that did that really hadn't
happened up until that point right
it would it happened through the talent
shows through video projects that was
when we began to work together
creatively and I think that now we had
done things like the stupid little radio
shows and stuff at the house right yeah
the pause tapes but what I found and of
course I'm going around I'm sampling
every friendship you know what I was
doing I was going to every single house
I was spending the night at everybody's
house and I had in mind not an agenda
but I just I sort of just naturally
carried with me an agenda without
thinking about it
it was just my personality to what
I want to have fun in a particular way I
am interested in having fun in this way
okay now we've got this radio I think
that we should do this radio show and
like we should do carrot we should do
voices and that kind of thing
there was no one else who was receptive
to that
besides you
I was all in you know what I'm saying no
one was receptive to that way of
thinking about
amusing themselves Ben was Ben was well
as we've discussed Ben was even more of
an ideas guy yeah right and he was more
out there and like I mean again when you
go over to his house and he's like let
me show you the new dance that I
invented like and it's kind of like
River Dance it's like I mean he was he
was a wild card he was amazing but yeah
I was very much like
yes I I had a sense of like
yeah we're gonna hang out we're gonna
we're gonna make stuff we're gonna do
stuff this is it this is it this is
amazing and regardless of what it was
this is a precursor to like the blood oh
thing but if we're yeah if we're gonna I
definitely had that sense of this if
we're gonna hang out for an afternoon
whether it was you know me and you or or
the three Ben was there or not it might
be like all right we're not just getting
together like we're getting together and
today's mission is fill in the blank go
out and cut down a tree
try to make a raft that we're going to
float in the backyard take some stuff
off of this tree and make a tea that Ben
said we should make because we found it
in a book in the library yeah we had
missions we had agendas and then go into
that sewer right it carried it carried
with a sense of mission and then that
was we we filled our time with that way
of thinking and then we also filmed any
creative Endeavor with the same sense of
mission like this is going to be good
and this has got to be the best thing
that we've ever done again we never
talked about it there was no like let's
have a meeting and figure this out right
it was in the natural thing where
and then with Ben sort of checking out
because of the health problems that he
was having I mean I still believe to
this day that if Ben had not had those
issues we the three of us would have
grown up and started something together
yeah you know I believe that it was
something creative together
look at this photo Rhett look at these
look at these photos of us from high
school look at that one describe it
um
this is your bathroom
at your house uh we're using a flash
camera because that's covering up your
face almost completely The Flash you're
in your letter jacket yep uh and we are
both I was a star soccer player in high
school we are both wearing
beanies which we would have called
tobaggins tobogans tobaggins well I
didn't say toeboggan I said toboggan now
I you know that's because I was born and
raised in North Carolina I moved to
North Carolina moved around
uh and they still have the price tags on
them what does it say on there I don't
know I can't figure that out but we we
bought these toboggans and we like to
take pictures of ourselves
I took one of you
that's a cool jacket very warm and then
you took you took one of me I don't know
that's a flattering face
and again we didn't take these pictures
and then immediately look at them we
took these pictures and then waited
maybe months before we could see him
again because he had to finish the roll
and then get it developed we could we
could have invented Instagram back then
doing pictures like this look at this I
mean look at how much fun we had you and
me
is that an index on that's a napkin with
your with your tongue being pressed
through it to make a hole I'm taking a
very point-blank close-up picture of you
and then outside of the focus range of
the camera you thought it was such a
good idea that then you took a picture
of me doing the same thing
and then here's one that's that's uh
it's tough to take a selfie
when you're um
you know when you can't when you can't
take a whole bunch of them so we were
having a good time now this is we were
this was such good friends this is
senior year
because you've got that jacket no no I
got the jacket after my freshman year
let I got my letter jacket as a freshman
are you a hundred percent sure of this
yeah because there was no JV soccer team
everybody was on the varsity soccer team
so I like they let you get it as a
freshman I was on the varsity soccer
team at every Varsity player got a
letter jacket well yeah I I no I thought
I'm 100 positive did you get it as a
freshman yes because it feels like a
little bit of a cheat code it did I
didn't
I I gotta just being honest with you I
played in one game a game that we won
nine to zero I know this because in the
yearbook my mom kept the um she kept the
schedule and she wrote down the score
and we were we were in the final four of
uh state playoffs that year
that was the peak of soccer yeah when I
was on the bench but I but I got my uh
I got my letter jacket and I think that
that's what I remember about starting
high school and it really had an impact
on our friendship because
you know we were so nervous we've
thought a lot about beginning high
school we were really in that headspace
when we were writing the lost causes of
Bleak Creek because we we put our
experiences into into that story and
there's so much expectation
but I actually
started playing soccer we had um
practice like six weeks before classes
began
and I remember being so nervous because
it's like okay I'm on the soccer team
there's no tryout everybody makes it
like I said but still I was nervous
because okay you got these upperclassmen
like all of a sudden I'm playing soccer
with seniors and juniors and I don't
know that many people from Bowie's Creek
who are going over here and playing
soccer you played soccer in middle
school because
everybody who likes soccer kind of
played but then in high school you
started to just uh matriculate so to
speak
so soccer for me was my introduction to
high school and you didn't have any part
of that
um and then that became a part of my
identity as a freshman as a soccer
player but I will say that talk about
season hadn't started I will say if you
don't remember this is that coach
Randall is that his name uh Randall uh
actively almost to the point of
harassment recruited me to be on the
soccer team as the goalie yes because
you were you could stretch out well
because I allowed one goal in middle
school one goal I was trained by you
remember Peter uh what was his name he
was his famous Campbell goalie that I
think is in like the Campbell Hall of
Fame for being a goalie Peter or
something
and my dad hired him to come and train
me oh wow and I remember being out in
the cold and having to learn how to do
that thing when you fall on your side
and then my dad got me like the
equipment layout yeah I got really good
I could do the drop kick you know and
I'm like six I was already six like five
going into school he would actively
like aggressively kind of like try to
bully me into being on the goalie it
almost worked he had an abrasive
personality uh I should have done it man
the stories we could have had coach
Brandon was the coolest guy but yeah you
should have done it man because well I
mean you were focused on basketball I
want to get rid of her basketball season
and um
man but yeah Chad Chad Hawley was a
senior and he was a really good keeper
he was great he was a great keeper he
played um
and again that's one of the reasons why
we went to like the Final Four
we had a pretty pretty good team but he
was a great keeper and um yeah he played
in college
but you would have been groomed
sophomore year you would have taken over
who ended up I know Brian Coleman did
was it goalie for a while no no he was
he was defense yeah he was a sweeper he
moved it really really far
he could do that thing where he would
where you're throwing him from the
sideline and he would you would get a
running start and he would put the ball
on the ground do a flip and then throw
it in yeah yeah and everybody would just
be like flabbergasted on the other team
and so they would just stop playing yeah
it was a great technique who was your
goalie uh Philip Hatcher became the
goalie remember him yeah and he was good
he was a glutton for punishment and you
kind of you have to be Fearless yeah
throwing yourself a little bit too
scared of like getting hurt also You
Gotta Throw Your Body around I don't
like getting hurt so of course I mean we
were best friends going into freshman
year but like
I had this like reconnaissance thing you
were on the cross country team though
and you guys started running before not
freshman year oh you weren't
my freshman year so once classes started
I felt like
I'm wearing my letter jacket I'm a part
of something I'm I'm getting in where I
fit in kind of thing I'm part of a team
it actually helped kind of kick start
things a little bit well my brother was
a senior that helped you
um and he was like a popular guy it was
you know one of the stars on the
basketball team
um and so there was this sort of a
little bit of a one a Runway set up for
becoming in as another McLaughlin right
um and I don't know it
I've never especially at that point in
my life I've never been one to like get
too nervous about the next stage I get
much more excited about the next stage
right and so
uh I remember going there was a before
school started that year there was a
athletes some sort of like athlete
I can't remember what it was but it was
at it was the first event at Harnett
Central before school started it was an
orgy outside uh in in the tobacco pit
where everybody smoked no it was just
some sort of get-together and my brother
was going and I was gonna go with him
and I just remember thinking a lot about
what I was going to wear and I wore
these shorts and of course I tucked a
polo shirt into them braided belt had a
braided belt there oh yeah went uh boy
it got close to the knee got close to
that tied into that knot and send it
south and no shoes I mean no socks and
uh loafers penny loafers with no socks
wow
um but you blend it in with that except
being very powerful So Tan you know that
like we sunscreen we didn't understand
that that was you believe in it didn't
we didn't think that was a thing that
you could do
um it was like you don't need sunscreen
unless you have red hair and I don't
have red hair when you get a tan that
becomes your sunscreen is what we mean
by the end of the summer boy you were
tan you know and you show up I just
remember walking into that setting with
just so much confidence oh you had
confidence well I mean you know going in
I didn't have going in as a freshman six
five you know you're you're looking down
on everybody you got a brother who's
already paved the way you know a lot of
people who are going to be there you
know what I'm saying you're good you're
not going you're bringing everyone from
your school because we were going buoys
Creek joined Lillington and Andrew all
together and Lafayette so that's still
the minority and that's how I looked at
it you know it's like we've got a we've
got a faction we're now we're now at
least a quarter of this a quarter of the
population is a minority right yeah yeah
that was enough though
but I mean yeah it was like and then all
these upperclassmen from all these other
places too you didn't you didn't know
them you really didn't know a lot of the
older buoys Creek people too so
I mean it was definitely an exciting
time I remember like there was a there
was no Commons area in
our elementary slash Middle School you
know where there was that break and
everybody would like
like hum haul around and Fiddle fart
around after homeroom after homeroom
so
what we discussed before for middle
school was more it was more like well
you lived on that side of town so you
had your friends and I was on the other
side of town alone now it was more of
okay I've got my soccer team
I've got some friends there I may you
know I made friends with Jason
from Andrew and like he would invite me
to his house
and I was like okay I'm hanging out with
other people
so our Horizons were expanding and our
friend group hadn't yet coalesced beyond
what what it would become in like
sophomore junior year we started to
develop like a
a friend group with some Lillington
people some Andrew people and a lot of
buoys Creek people and we had a pretty
tight group there for a couple of years
but I remember freshman year it was It
was kind of this
branching out
I didn't really I I didn't
that is true but I didn't see it that
way it's yeah it's not something we ever
talked about because I I sent more in
retrospect I definitely had this again
we talked about it uh that summer
between eighth and ninth grade and you
know going and swimming in the river and
this is when we had
at that point definitely our friendship
with Ben had really transformed and so
that summer going to the river was
something that was pretty much me and
you uh there we still hung out with Ben
when he was like when he felt up to it
but that he didn't there was a lot of
times we didn't feel up to it and and
making that phone call and seeing if he
was feeling okay
it just created this thing that me and
you became this unit and so yeah we
talked about what we were going to
experience what we were going to do and
of course I was talking a lot about all
the women that were going to be
um here at this place but there's a
thousand people you know we're going to
this place that's got that many more
women
and
I saw us as this like unit that I kind
of just took that for granted that like
okay well I'm not going to try to find
another best friend or anything you know
it's like and I never I did
I I know I was never threatened I didn't
think there was anything that was all
going to fall apart at this point yeah
we were I mean we were getting we were
definitely getting closer than ever but
it was the first time that we had
aspects of our high school identity that
were completely separate like you as a
basketball player right
yeah I mean there was a little bit of
that in in middle school but it began to
develop more but I was friends with
everybody on the basketball team like in
high school I wasn't friends with
anybody on the basketball team that's
true because you know because it's all
all new new students and there's a lot
more of them so you you know the ones
that you're kind of hanging out with
yeah I mean the thing I started to
experience this
I now I kind of understand it as the
chameleon-like quality of an Enneagram
three
that I never really understood was a
thing until started looking like a
personality evaluations but that's a
tendency to
sort of infiltrate a particular group
and be a version of yourself in that
group in order to excel in that group
and so there was sort of the basketball
version of me right which is a totally
different set of friends because they're
all in the basketball team in kind of a
different way of being like that version
of Rhett was
pretty serious and like committed and
worried about being good at basketball
and like kind of thought he was pretty
cool because it wasn't a silly
environment did you have locker room
slang
um I I don't remember that but I'm maybe
um you were like boy I'm I'm I'm flaming
some hoops tonight but you know how you
get into a certain environment
uh where and the basketball team
is different than the soccer team right
because the basketball team is way
smaller than the soccer team or way
smaller than the football team there's
this sense that you're like Hey we're
the 12 guys
bet they chose for this right there's
just this sense that like you're kind of
in this uh Elite group of guys and guys
especially sort of like
Embrace that and kind of start to feel
like this cool gang you would wear your
uniform to class on the day you know you
wore a suit oh that's right you wore a
suit you had to wear a suit and tie that
was the rule you had to wear a suit and
tie on game day oh wow yeah that's
that's wild yeah and so well and that
was really once we were on Varsity which
was started for me started sophomore
year okay but the point I'm making is
that there's this like mode there's a
sort of a social code amongst the
basketball team where I'm behaving in a
different way and as soon as I'm outside
of that environment I'm not that guy
anymore I'm silly Class Clown Rhett you
know which is what I was most of the
time and then of course with you like we
were like it was a whole different level
of taking silliness taking selfies with
I mean I I just I want to emphasize the
embarrassing level of silliness that we
were still I mean we never really
stopped
but
yeah it was just it was so so stupid we
acted so stupid it was it was fun man oh
yeah I mean when I read through once I
started looking at these yearbooks and I
started reading everybody's notes
that was it it helped put things back in
perspective first of all we went to
Trinidad after our freshman year of high
school on that mission trip
because all of our uh friends all of our
church friends were talking about we
were going in like you know the school
year it ended and this is like the big
thing we're like going to Trinidad so
that's when that happened but every
single person called me crazy like I I
was I was I guess I was I'm pleasantly
surprised and I'm sure the same goes for
you because people would write about me
and people would write about us
and then our closest friends like
Michael and Trent
they would write about me and you you
know it's like we were these uh
ring leaders amongst a group of guy
friends because we had these we were
super silly we were super crazy
um all the girls just thought we like
had and I'm projecting my notes on to
you because I know it's true of you too
because I just read these it's like all
the girls just thought and our friend
group just thought we were just crazy
thank you for making us laugh all the
time that type of thing
and then there were people who were not
in our friend group who were on the edge
who would say it a little bit
differently like
you were the craziest person I've ever
met I don't I have no clue you know it's
like we were
we were just and it was a silliness it
wasn't like it it wasn't like jackass
like Johnny Knoxville like they'll and
we would do some some daring things but
it really was more about just cutting
the fool like being the butt of the joke
if I had to be that type of thing class
clowns and it and us being a unit that
would bring other people into it like
people our friend group the way that I
can see in the yearbook is that they all
fed off of our energy and it's just
something sometimes I feel like we've
developed
personas because we have
it was nice to go back and like have
like a 98 uh
agreement amongst notes that like we
were that way then too
prior experience we went to North
Carolina State University
in in the fall of 1996. things were
different than we drove it was like a 45
minute drive for my home
I was roommates with my best friend
since first grade hey that's me and
we didn't really know anybody else but
we knew that we were going to get
involved in
an organization called campus Crusade
and I I think that that would as we
talked about that defines a big part of
our experience that organization as well
as we'll share later yeah that's right
um
and I had well just to set the stage
even further I had a serious girlfriend
who was a junior in high school
and
I would go home every weekend to see her
and also to get my laundry done and to
pick up all the cans of mellow yellow
that my mom had bought me um Melia was
not available in Raleigh
it was but we had to buy it with your
own money right uh I did have a job on
campus I worked at the genetics lab like
the work study program I was washing the
dishes of the
um of the the scientists who were doing
some sort of genetic experiments on corn
I then had to clean all the beakers and
test tubes and that's a meticulous
process if you're sure they weren't just
eating corn and you were cleaning their
actual dishes I think that's that is
possible I think they were selling you
on like you're involved in the science
here and you're just washing dishes of
scientists you like corn I mean if they
were feeding themselves with pipettes
then I guess that's what I'm saying that
happened one one kernel at a time
it's a great way to eat corn and really
helps with portion control we had
visited campus once at least I think
Michael juby's Michael juby's dad
took us to campus our senior year and
like we walked around Camp well we only
applied
to two schools Carolina and State
uh both were accepted to both I thought
we applied to uh UNC Asheville to their
film school we didn't actually know we
didn't actually apply we were going to
but we got talked out that was like that
was more junior year the conversation
when I thought I might play basketball
there
but no in the end we only applied to
Carolina and state and they got accepted
into engineering there was serious
consideration of going to Carolina I
mean I the story I tell is I applied to
Carolina so that I could get accepted
and then say no to reject them but the
reality is I I was not like a loyal
State fan versus Carolina I was actually
sort of like going up a Duke fan I was a
State fan you were a State fan and I I
didn't really felt like I couldn't do it
I didn't have a lot of Allegiance but
women boy once I dyed my
backside into wolf pack red I think
that's how you do it you stick your butt
in the blood when you get there just
kind of dip it uh the wolf blood there
was no going back no we'll die the blue
the entire pack donated a little bit of
blood so they were they were a little
peekish for a few days but they you know
no wolves were harmed ultimately in the
butt dipping of blood
I remember that we we both brought our
bikes to campus we've oh yeah we had
never been on a place so large that you
were expected to walk across the whole
thing well we've been riding our bikes a
lot just we always rode our bikes it was
part of our identity it was part of our
brand it was we're boys with bikes well
once we got licenses not so much but
but I think someone had told us like
that's a really big campus and you guys
are way over there on East Campus in
sign dorm so I mean it's going to take
you you know a couple of days to get to
the other side of Campus if you have to
walk well to get to the dining room it
did take I mean it probably took 20
minutes to walk to just walk straight
yeah
all the way across campus to the dining
hall
which that was that was fun you know
having that Excursion bag milk like seen
like who from your dorm you could get to
get together with and I'll leave at the
same time but we're still waiting for
you where's Hugh he's up there being
weird in his dorm room we're gonna have
to leave him
remember Hugh unfortunately I don't
must have been never even maybe that
wasn't memorable
he's an interesting guy Emma Grant Grant
oh you grant he's an actor yeah Grant is
his name not you you where's you I don't
know of you
maybe maybe he would show up if uh I
knew his name was Grant
um but yeah we'd ride our bikes all
around campus but
the thing now that I superimposed on the
experience
is just what an opportunity for
a
I'll call it a fresh start but we I mean
we were
bleaching our hair and like you were I
was I was turning your hair into like a
giraffe pattern that looked absolutely
amazing but was mistaken as a soccer
ball we would how many soft girls are
black and yellow some but I mean it's a
giraffe come on I knew it was a trap but
I'm just saying a lot of people thought
it was red white and blue for July 4th
over that this summer leading into our
yeah got to be patriotic freshman year
in college so like we were wearing these
the huge jinko jeans with the chain
wallet and uh the thrift store shirts
like the thrift store golf shirts yeah
and our and our hair what my hair was
like standing up and and bleached and
that even went into my sophomore year
because that's when Christy and I met
and like
the last time my hair was like big and
bleached was when we first met and then
it started to tone down
over the course of the professional well
we we weren't in the Band anymore but
like as freshmen like we had a very
assertive looks
you know I mean you were tall as all get
out and and and and scarily skinny right
and with these huge jeans it just looked
I mean you're we're riding these bikes
around I look like Gumby I mean were
those jeans I never really thought about
the you know I enjoyed
getting attention for the way that I
looked
but at the same time this may be hard to
believe at the same time I do not
honestly recall having this awareness
that everyone was looking at me as I
rode my bike across campus but we we
were some of the more aesthetically
notable people on campus I'm not saying
we were cool looking we were just
different but to put that in proper
context it wasn't that difficult in 1996
at NC State University to stand out just
to stand out
you know it's probably much more
difficult today we stood out more than I
thought I did in my own mind
even though I did it him on purpose I
don't know it's just weird how I can
hold those two truths but so we didn't I
didn't make a switch we kind of doubled
down I think with the way that we looked
so it was just like I think hearing
friends talk about it later they were
like wow these guys are different given
the nature of the thing that we got
involved with which was campus you know
Christian campus ministry we got
involved with a lot of people from very
similar backgrounds on very similar
trajectories as we were right and I
think the thing that I regret is not
intentionally connecting with people who
were different than me of course NC
State was different in 1996 but it
wasn't that different there were people
from all walks of life from all social
and economic backgrounds from all over
the world all kinds of interesting
perspectives and things that were being
exchanged and we closed ourselves right
into the you know southern white
Conservative Christian uh heterosexual
group you know what I'm saying and just
real real hard at that
uh and I wish that could have been like
oh and but my mentality was not my
mentality going into college at the time
was one of other perspectives are not
only different but necessarily wrong I'm
coming to this campus with the truth I'm
bringing the correct world view to this
worldly place and when you go into a
situation believing that you've got the
truth and it is your job to dispense the
truth to the worldly corrupted people
around you yeah making connections with
them becomes a transactional thing where
the only reason you're not really
conducive to True friendship you make it
you make it it becomes transactional
because I'm only befriending you so that
I can share the gospel with you so that
I can tell you what the truth is and
most people aren't receptive to that so
you end up just hanging out with all the
conservative white people who are
receptive to that who believe the same
thing it's a problem so I wish I hadn't
done that right yeah and all you all we
had to do was make a list of
acquaintances you don't have to make it
this weighty thing where it's like I
have to I have to build meaningful
long-lasting friendships with all these
different type of people that you know
that sets the bar really high and it's
intimidating but just having one one
conversation with somebody you know in
the first couple of weeks on campus
there's this thing that we've talked
about called campus face yeah you you
just need to know that it's going to
happen if you're on that type of Campus
where you're walking around and you're
seeing the same faces over the course of
a year and at a certain point you
realize I know this person's face but
I've never met them or talked to them
and it's nice to have a few people that
you've at least said something to like
leaned over in class and said like
have you is this your first time taking
chemistry I just made that up on top of
my head because then it's like if it's
chemistry 101 probably okay it's a
stupid question yeah that would be my
follow-up it's your name mark that was
just a stupid question whoever wanted it
to be just to ask you just just so I
could like break the ice do you have any
pets uh you know I think so some another
type of person that's on my list and it
would also take the heat off of the
criticism we placed on ourselves that
you just laid on us and we deserve it is
athletes like I would like I would put
an athlete on my list or maybe you'd be
my I want to be friends with a football
player and I want to be friends with uh
track and field Artist Artist or a
graffiti artist that's someone I would
like to know in my life now I think I
think I can make a list of acquaintances
now yeah this is not pretty much
is is gonna be in the top five for me
but athletes had attendance they they
lived in this bubble on campus which we
penetrated because we were so far from
the dining hall
that they allowed us at the extreme east
side of campus to go to the much closer
athletic dining hall Case Case dining
hall named Metro Coach Everett case much
smaller it was much better food much
better food they had steak steaks yeah
and it was only athletes except for the
people from our like the three dorms way
over there where we were yeah and so
it's like these scrawny kids and like
really huge clubs I was mistaken as a
member of the basketball team many times
so don't don't leak don't put me into
the scrawny kids with big clothes groups
I may have thought that you were the
manager for the for the basketball team
but they thought I was on the basketball
team and I went with that okay the Lunch
Ladies did but the other athletes knew
who was on the basketball team and you
weren't one of them so it was like Yeah
we actually got these strange looks and
we stopped going but I went there enough
to know and we had we did have a few
athlete friends we had a football player
friend our roommates not roommates but
our right next door we're both on the
football team and then uh Jackie was a
swimmer yeah and they're so isolated
they're in this bubble they do nothing
but Sports I mean so it really goes for
them too they need to make a list of
like hey I need to have a couple of
acquaintances who
aren't athletic well so that I can
realize that the world is much broader
but now they get in the NCAA athletes
can get sponsored so now you can like
hang out with somebody who's got like a
deal with like the local Italian
restaurant
[Laughter]
Jesse and I got married
uh and so then we're living in Chapel
Hill but I'm she's going to school I'm
still commuting to Black and Beach
you're married to Christy you're an apex
going like we're both sort of
establishing ourselves at like different
churches you know you're going to church
in Apex I'm going to church in Chapel
Hill which obviously as you know from
our backstory that's a really big part
of our lives so getting involved there
is like something that's kind of
unfolding right
but this is how the seed of what we do
now was still there and it was more of
like a sapling because it had been
planted early in our lives and in high
school and in college with all the weird
stuff that we did together videos that
we made
but because we had been asked to
MC Christmas conference and that was
something that was still happening
what we did is we said let's get
together
hell or high water let's get together
once a week at one of our homes and
we're going to just do creative things
we're going to we're going to write
songs we're going to conceptualize video
Concepts Etc all with this goal of
hey we've got a we've got to fill these
spots come December with these
entertaining ideas that we have
but boy I just if we had not had had
that right
that first of all that regular like we
had a goal we had something that we were
working towards but then we had this
we're going to get together and that's
how we're going to incubate this
creative side of us
if we had not made that decision who
knows what we would be doing today and
where we would be yeah I think that I
mean we were we were we were hanging out
like we were making plans yeah as like
the four of us as couples I'm sure we
did stuff together I'm sure we did stuff
with Greg and his wife Jen and like
we were all hanging out and doing stuff
but it wasn't every weekend and we were
living in you know we were living 40
minutes apart and we also had no money
and we had no money so so the ability to
like well let's go out to eat it's like
well hold on our grocery budget is 200
right and uh that's all for all the
groceries for the month and our eating
out budget is like a hundred dollars so
I think we'll go through that pretty
fast I'm just getting at the fact that I
don't
I think that if we hadn't had that
weekly Workshop
like on Thursday nights whenever it was
that I mean I I think our friendship
would have suffered at that point you
know we were working towards a common
goal of like we have this audience of
1300 college students at the end of the
year
sure it's only February but let's go
ahead and we're so we took we were so
committed to it and um I I think that
that's
had to I mean it was a big con I don't
know if it was a Lifeline or a
friendship but it was certainly a big
contributor to us being
um staying close and and having this
thing to to work on together so it
wasn't just hey let's get together once
or twice a month whenever we we can get
our our weekend schedules to line up and
when we got together we not only worked
on like
conceptualizing skits a lot of it was
writing songs too I do remember that
because
um
I remember writing that attribute to
friendship song it's like
that story song you wrote that wasn't
even funny for any reason I remember
getting together in the the apartment
before
the one that you moved into so I guess
we started it pretty early or maybe you
moved into that I don't remember going
to that the sanland Place apartment and
getting together I remember when I moved
out of 3000c there was a there was a few
months that we would still get together
there
and then I remember because there was a
semester in which we still all lived
there when you moved after you got
married and then when you got married
well not not just a few months not not
like that summer we lived there that
summer okay you got married in June we
continued to stay there for the summer
like leading up to the end of the 12
month lease
but then I I definitely remember driving
after working as an engineer like
getting on the road telling remember
Christy this is the night that I don't
come home because I leave work and I'm
going to Rhett's house and like Jesse
would like she was like
newlywed I'm Gonna Make You guys dinner
and want to be Rhett's friends coming
over and they're going to work on their
stuff
well partly because they had told us to
keep
doing that you know right it's all
around the same time Greg's wedding
where we wrote a song for his that's
right rehearsal dinner and they and
Jesse and Chris were like you guys need
to keep doing this because the other
thing that was happening it wasn't just
preparing for Christmas conference but I
don't remember what year it was but
right around this time is when Cole
asked us to do the uh the show at
Carolina like the one night only thing
which we talked about this whole we're
kind of getting into this some that
stage that we talked about before but
that gave us something else to work
towards yeah uh it was all in the like a
there wasn't there were not many years
in which
we ever thought I mean I kind of knew
going into engineering that it wasn't a
permanent thing for me because I tried
to like change the communications
because I thought I was just going to go
into Ministry
I was like I'm gonna go on stent or
something I'm gonna be on Stafford
Crusade eventually but I got I gotta
wait until Jesse graduates so we can do
that so I I was a little bit more in
love with the stability of the job and
it was a good paint job and at that
point we weren't necessarily thinking
about doing it together like there was
no path to because what you did is You
full time you went on stent
entertainment are you like you got a job
at like a campus but it wasn't until
Cole asked us to do that show Shane Dyke
saw us do that show it's like you guys
should do something as a position yada
yada all that stuff led to so we were
also working on that but so we were
pretty diligent like getting together
every week working on stuff
um developing developing our craft as
crappy as it was but we weren't the the
some funny observations I make now
we were not uh like performing for
anybody there was no Outlet it was like
no go to somebody's house and write some
songs knowing that we will perform these
for a bunch of college students at some
point but it wasn't like hey what if we
went to a comedy club like we never
thought to this day I've never performed
at a comedy club right never I've never
done any anything else most people would
think is lost a logical way to go about
things we didn't view comedy at clubs
yeah never never been to one not only
didn't perform it had never been to one
there's like a famous One
Charlie Goodnights in Raleigh which I
think is gone now but yeah but we didn't
yeah we didn't do any never never
crossed our minds that we would do that
or we would be like well let's put on
like let's put on a little show or let's
go and
perform in this context
because it was very much about live
performance because it was like we're
gonna have this these students attention
uh but it's just it's funny because we
were yeah we were doing these things
that were that feel very like you gotta
like get your stuff together we're
always
responsible and dependable to a thought
yeah I think I would still categorize Us
in that way uh you know like we we carry
out our lives and our business
in our relationships in a very
responsible and dependable way almost
sometimes so much that that it can get
in the way of just like the being a
weird creative person we never did
anything because we felt like it we
always did something because we had
obligated ourselves to do it and then
it's like well that just means we like
we have to do it it doesn't matter what
you feel about it right okay well this
is good this is the way that you have to
do this if you're going to have this
apartment and you got to get these guys
to do this and you got to do the repairs
and then you got to get this job and you
have to do it in this way and do this
presentation in this way
we were all thinking that same way and
then when the opportunity to apply that
principle to entertainment came along in
a very weird way that it came along for
us we applied the same level of
process to it that has we've just kind
of carried over for the past 17 18 years
to up to this point it's um
but we've thankfully been able to do it
in a way that now yes
we are different people in a lot of ways
right in terms of like what is your day
like and what are you thinking about how
are you approaching things yes there's
still this like sense of responsibility
and Duty
to our family and our you know employees
and making sure that these things are
done in the right way still very
important to us it's like ingrained
Never Gonna Get rid of it
but yeah it's like if you if if that
version of me in that version of you
were to come into this room right now
and sit down
uh first of all I would be like hey man
I have a few a few style tips
yeah but I would also be like it's going
to be interesting to see uh the way that
that evolves over the next 20 years for
you as you start to think about it a
little bit more right
uh but then and then of course we would
have a really interesting spiritual
conversation
because we were very locked in on a very
particular way of thinking about things
and we're 100 sure without doubt that we
were right about it
um and so that would have been an
interesting conversation to see who what
we have become the Heretics
um that we have become
um but
I think that if we were to have a
conversation about the creative things
that we're doing
if we were to be like let me tell you
what we did yesterday oh God we'd flip
out yeah oh yes we get to do that
because we never that we never give
ourselves full permission to just like
just put the dream out there it was like
we didn't talk about the dream all the
time we talked about the thing that we
were working on the next thing and it
wasn't like if you have a band and
you're like you talk about the dream of
getting a record deal you know there's a
path like because there was no set path
it was like okay this may be all we've
got we've got this show at the end of
the year that well we're emceeing this
conference we're just going to turn it
into our show when we get our 10-minute
segments and then your brother's like
hey come to Carolina and talk to my
students and make it into a comedy show
it was like
okay we can obsess about that but it
wasn't
there were no we couldn't connect those
dots to any larger dreams so
it was very much like scrambling around
in the dark
and it was unspoken a lot of times you
know
um what it is we were working towards
because you know it didn't exist
so you know I give us a lot of credit
that with no path with no
um instruction manual
we still found a way to like stick with
it to get we're going to get together we
have these we have these isolated events
and we're going to obsess about them
and that was fun and fulfilling and I
hope it can be encouraging for for
people you know because again
it doesn't have to be the case like you
know if you're if you're if you've got a
job right now you're working doing
something
um first of all make the most of what it
is that you're doing if I find as much
joy as you can in it you know uh but
maybe there's something meet a Nigerian
but maybe there's get married there's
something that is
um a point of passion that you don't
necessarily understand how that could
even be a career and maybe it isn't
maybe it's just a really awesome hobby
yeah but I just think it's important to
see that thing like a little plant
yeah and that plant needs things
that plant doesn't need to be put into
the attic and covered because it will
die give it a little something you'll
have to find a new seed somewhere right
all right there it is hashtag your
biscuits let us know what you think
about all this please leave us a
voicemail with how you're processing
things 1-88 earpod one
yeah okay Rhett and Link My name is is
Rachel and I'm calling from Arizona I'm
a teacher here and my high school
students are reading the lost causes of
Bleak Creek just wanted to give you guys
a shout out the kids are really liking
it have a good day bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]